my name is Luke Cage if you're like me
and you binge watched all 13 hours of
Luke Cage your brain is probably much
along with forgetting to feed yourself
you might have missed these references
here our top 5 favorite Easter eggs from
Luke Cage number 5 Stan Lee's cameo
Lee's face can be seen on a poster in
the 12th episode of Luke Cage when Luke
stops a robbery and runs into Method Man
there you see Stan dressed as a police
officer urging citizens to report any
crimes they may see also Luke and
methods swap sweatshirts besties number
4 Colleen wing in episode 13 Claire
temple finds a flyer for martial arts
training by Colleen wing in the comics
Colleen is misty Knight's partner in
Heroes for Hire a group started by Luke
Cage
she's also friends with Luke cages
partner and the next Marvel hero to get
his own show Danny Rand or iron fist
number 3
Power Man Power Man as the moniker Luke
Cage decides to go by after being in the
hero game for a while and realizing that
he needs to up his brand pop calls him
this and what sounds like an inside joke
and we get the joke pop not a problem
for you power man number 2 Back to the
Future in episode 10 misty Knight is
looking at microfiche newspaper records
for Carl Lucas Luke cages name before he
gained his powers she finds the article
she needs in the article that we all
want an obvious homage to Back to the
Future with changes to prevent copyright
issues Martin Brown and McFly are
referenced as well as a thrust capacitor
we're going we don't need roads
number one the classic cage costume this
is an obvious one for comic book readers
after escaping from Seagate prison with
his fashionable tiara and cuffs cage
comes across a baggy yellow shirt
it's a weird moment for comic book
readers cage looks at his reflection for
30 seconds and realizes what we all knew
for 30 years he looks ridiculous
sometimes the comic books don't
translate to the screen but kudos to the
producers for throwing it in there for
us for more on your favorite comic books
TV shows and movies check out gamespot
universe